there's one thing that we keep coming
back to and this idea of chewing
complete what does it mean and why do we
need to worry about it yeah what does it
mean to say as a language it's usually
in this context a programming language
is or is not Turing complete well
obvious first example is that every
programming language you're familiar
with I mean will refer to the usual
suspects Fortran basic Pascal COBOL C
C++ Java they are all Turing complete so
what fundamentally does a thing have to
be in order to be Turing complete and
the answer is it needs to be able to do
everything the deterring machine can do
most fully we have made several videos
on this topic some for me some from my
colleague Mark Jago and we have visited
quite a lot of these issues
just a recap a Turing machine is thought
of as an endless infinite piece of tape
and it has a read/write head that goes
over the top of the marks on that tape
which can be anything you like but
conventionally to keep it very simple
you say it's zeros and ones and you can
show that just the ability to read and
write on an infinite piece of tape
patterns of zeros and ones is powerful
enough to compute anything that can be
computed admittedly your low-level
turing program with all its zeros and
ones maybe ten trillion times longer
than your compartir program i don't know
but in principle it can do exactly the
same some people argue that actually
although it was Turing that made brought
this all to our attention in the late
thirties with the work he did in some
ways some people would say it really
owes we call Babbage complete because
another UK well he was a computer
scientist actually in the way his brain
worked Charles Babbage many of you know
he started off by just doing
very powerful calculating machines
difference engines while going beyond
that some of you will know the Charles
Babbage said well that's just like a
calculator that you have in your top
pocket
but where's about ten tons and full of
cog wheels but even just using cog
wheels he went on and said I want to do
something that really can compute in the
way that a human can do and the one
thing he realized straightaway is to
make it really powerful enough you must
at very minimum have what was called in
those days conditional branching if
statements you've got to be able to say
that I'm going to look at a certain cell
on my tape and if it's got a 1 in it I'm
going to do this thing and if you're a
zero and it I'm going to do that thing
so it's this sort of two-way choice that
an if-then-else statement can give you
and he said it's absolutely vital to be
able to do that because very often the
computations that humans do depend on
the precise nature of the data they are
given some data will so anyone where
some days will send you another so this
conditional branching is absolutely
vital and as a sort of kind of result of
side effect of that it's also implicitly
means that you've got to have the
ability to go to somewhere different in
your memory for example you might be
saying if this condition is true then I
carry on with a sequence of instructions
that immediately follow but on the other
hand if the else statement is true then
I have to go off somewhere else and do
something different
now all our undergraduates we absolutely
do not encourage the raw use of go twos
because it's not good well structured
programming but those who would learn
assembler will know under the hood you
can't avoid it you really do have go-to
statements which say I'm here at
location 88 or whatever now jump off to
location 200 so if you like the
conditional branching implant
is a go-to in that you might stay in
this part of the tape you might jump off
somewhere else
we've seen on the Turing machine videos
it's perfectly possible to get your
read/write head chattering across the
tape until it finds a pattern that it
likes the look the other thing for
turing completeness is you must be able
to have arbitrary amount of memory at
the very basic level you must be able to
have a long enough tape in either
direction and on modern machines what
that means is the totality of the RAM
that you possess you must be able to get
as much memory as the problem needs so
that's the fundamental thing then as
much memory as you need and conditional
branching and that the bedrock that is
what you absolutely must have if a
Turing machine has in principle
unlimited memory yeah
none of our computers or Turing machines
and Shawn I'm so glad you asked that
question and I didn't prompt you I
didn't prime you in any way but yes you
can say that absolutely none of our
so-called infinitely powerful Turing
machines can be because they've all got
finite memory and if you go back to the
Chomsky hierarchy you will find if you
can have arbitrary amounts of memory and
if things might go on forever and you
never know whether they're going to
terminate or not in the general case
then you're in Chomsky type zero the
moment you say are but it's got to
terminate within a finite amount of
memory you're down in Chomsky type one
so you can say yes essentially
finiteness of memory enforces that
restriction on you anyway down to type 1
instead of type 0
first of all what does the cheering
machine actually look like what does it
do
so here we are then this we also get a
question and it will give us an answer
yes or no these